usually what we do is if say we have
commissioned a recipe from a recipe
developer or chef we will tell them what
we want and then once we get there
espeon we will have an editor go over it
very carefully and ask the developer or
the chef or the cookbook author all of
the questions like are you you know it's
just the right amount of salt is this
are you sure you meant to do this is
this the right timing for this or that
and then once we've got all the
questions answered we then ask somebody
else to test it in a home kitchen not a
you know some kind of high-tech kitchen
but in fact a home kitchen that everyone
would have so we can make sure of times
you know because different ranges and
ovens will react differently so we want
to make sure we're using kind of the
broadest range technology and we have
that test it and they will often have
questions themselves so things will get
tested recipes can get tested two three
and four times before the finished
product before we actually feel like
this is completely dummy proof everyone
can do it and then we have it you know
copy edit and put on the site the
magazines that we use for our database
do the same thing they test in their
their kitchens both in New York and in
LA relentlessly so and they both tests
on both home and professional equipment
to make sure it works so we really know
that those recipes will definitely work
because there's nothing worse than
inviting people over and making a big
dinner and then you think oh this wasn't
so good I'm kind of embarrassed you know
so it's very important to us that the
recipes are absolutely doable and a
success from the beginning
you